last time we talked - speaking of eating
you were on keto diet I was on keto diet
how'd it go it was you know here's the
thing that's cute
here's what I learned very quickly the
keto diet what about as good as mine
well here's the thing with the keto diet
we've never been sicker it's very hard
to you know do it cuz I because what
happens is you start making little you
start making little adjustments sure and
they become large they turn into
boulders they turn into real problems
turns into real if you first start
shehenshah catch so catch up just
started I said you start on the children
- so right so I was like I could just
have a cheeseburger give a cheeseburger
but what if I just use that lit like I
literally I started I swear to God just
being like like a little like I would
just - - no yeah she can I say
cheeseburger you're not having the bun
right no no it's a burger no cheese I'm
not an idiot
I don't know so when I was doing it I
was really trying yeah and then I do a
little ketchup and then when you have a
little ketchup you you're like something
awakens in you yeah something awakens oh
you mean your mind awakens we like this
yeah the demon awakens and it's like hey
I bet you could have a dash of something
else I'm like I bet you're right and
then you start because on the keto it's
like how many carbs a day is supposed to
have like it's like it's a very low
number but it's a certain amount of
training your last there's one of your
last right which is sorry it's like a
bite of a cracker but in your head
you're like I I could have a little
taste of a lot of different things in
it's 20 or less I started chewing things
and then spin it out yeah yeah Oh dark
chocolate okay cuz it says it's okay I
can't have a whole bar turns red but I
would harass you you have to have a tiny
little bite right before you go to bed
or something cuz if that's what keeps
your thing going on that and then I
would just be like I would just have a
bar and just kind of fight you know what
else I found with keto is I found myself
eating a sh way more calories than I was
eating on a regular diet but I'd like to
its keto so it's all fat and protein but
still 10,000 calories 10,000 calories
and I gotta just stay home and keep all
of your orbs 10,000 calories 10,000 I
gotta stay away from carbs and sugar
just for the most part because like
that's my problem I problem everybody's
Broncs everybody's but they say calories
have different hormonal effects in your
body
do for sure but if yeah but if you're
eating a shitload I don't what dive you
had a lot of counting a lot of color and
you're not burning it is a problem yeah
yeah yeah and the keto thing with me is
there like you can eat cheese so it got
a little ridiculous a little ridiculous
I got a little absurd yeah - I was
eating cheese's that don't even go
together
- I was eating like cheddar and fresh
mozzarella every I was just like this is
even real but you know I watched Anthony
Bourdain and he had at one of his no
reservations on Sardinia yeah so
Sardinia is some beautifully and they
live the bits it's one of the blue zones
they live forever literally like honored
yeah if you see the way they eat they in
or they oh I don't know um [ __ ]
sausage every meal right big wheels of
cheese red wine yeah really much [ __ ]
like do they make their feta right there
I mean it everything comes from right
there in their garden okay problem so
hungry watching it you all they're
eating they're eating so much of the
things they tell you not to eat and they
were talking doing eventually I want to
slam my door found it they're all having
and they still are all big they're all
the interesting there are farmers know I
thought you're saying they're like
shredded no it just built to be fat and
then dying it forever they may live
forever they don't look great
well but at the same time they live did
I start eating the Sami when they want
old yeah yeah yeah but then so then they
go for a house bummer you go rail sauce
has no carbs or no sugar is good right
and it's really good it's alright so
it's like I was like okay what if I were
to drink it like what happens is you
start you start using so much like
copious America to Bristol Farms and
come out with nine rail sauces like what
do you do are you like if you want a
Canadian company I started
OD'ing a Buffalo cauliflower and then
yeah pine nuts
yeah high nuts upper body bags of pine
nuts you know many calories in just one
cup of pine nuts like 800 that's not
even Tyler fat to Florentine is a lot of
people getting depressed and it's easy
to eat when you're depressed so and when
you're bored a nothing all right yeah so
I've now try to eat better because I'm
like I could really fall into a problem
being in the morning weather and like
just is it there's like you me have the
same energy nice right now yeah yeah
yeah yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]